is there a part of you that's frustrated
by the rate of progress and blue origin
blue origin needs to be much faster and
it's one of the reasons that I left my
role as the CEO of Amazon uh a couple of
years ago I needed I wanted to come in
and um blue origin needs me right now
and so I had always when I was the CEO
of Amazon my point of view on this is if
I'm the CEO of a publicly company is
going to get my full attention and I
really it's just how I think about
things I it was very important to me I
felt I had an obligation to all the
stakeholders at Amazon uh to do that um
and so having you know turned the CE I
was still the executive chair there but
I turned the CEO role over and the
reason the primary reason I did that is
so that I could spend time on Blue
origin adding some
you know energy some sense of urgency we
need to move much faster and we're going
to uh what are the ways to speed it up
so I mean there's
uh you've talked a lot of different ways
to sort of uh an
Amazon um you know removing uh
barriers for for progress or
Distributing making everybody autonomous
and self-reliant in terms all the all
those kinds of things is that apply blue
or or it does apply I know I'm leading
this directly we are going to become the
world's most decisive company across any
industry and so you know at Amazon for
you know for ever since the beginning I
said we're going to become the world's
most customer obsessed
company and no matter the industry like
people one day people are going to come
to Amazon from the healthcare industry
and want to know how did you guys how do
you how are you so customer obsessed how
do you act not just pay lip service that
but actually do that um and from you
know all all different Industries should
come on to study us to see how we
accomplish that and the analogous thing
at Blue origin and what will help us
move faster is we are going to become
the world's most decisive company we're
going to get really good at taking
appropriate technology risk making those
decisions quickly um you know being bold
those things that's what and having the
right culture that supports that you
need people to be ambitious technically
ambitious you know if there are five
ways to do something we'll study them
but let's study them very quickly and
make a decision we can always change our
mind uh it doesn't you know changing
your mind is I talk about oneway doors
and two-way doors most
decisions are two-way doors can you
explain that cuz I I love that uh
metaphor for if you make the wrong
decision if it's a two-way door decision
you walk out the door you pick a door
you walk out you spend a little time
there it turns out to be the wrong
decision you can come back in and pick
another door some decisions are so
consequential and so important and so
hard to reverse that they really are
one-way door decisions you go in that
door you're not coming back and those
decisions have to be made very
deliberately very carefully um if you
can think of yet another way to analyze
the decision you should slow down and do
that so you know uh when I was CEO of
Amazon I often found myself in the
position of being the chief slowdown
officer because somebody would be
bringing me a one-way door decision and
I would say okay I can think of three
more ways to analyze that so let's go do
that because we H we are not going to be
able to reverse this one easily maybe
you can reverse it it's going to be very
costly and very timec consuming we
really have to get this one right from
the
beginning and
uh what happens unfortunately in
companies what can happen is that you
have a one siiz fits-all decision making
process where you end up using the
heavyweight
process on all decisions yeah including
the lightweight ones the two-way door
decisions two-way door decisions should
mostly be made by single individual ual
or by very small teams deep in the
organization and oneway door decisions
are the ones that that are the
irreversible ones those are the ones
that should be elevated up to you know
the senior most Executives who should
slow them down and make sure that the
right thing is being done yeah I mean
part of the skill here is to to know the
difference between one way and two way I
think you yes yeah I mean I think you
mentioned Amazon
Prime uh the decision to sort of create
Amazon Prime as a one-way door and I
mean it's not it's unclear if it is or
not but it probably is and it's a really
big risk to go there there are a bunch
of decisions like that that are you
know changing the decision is going to
be very very complicated some of them
are technical decisions too because some
technical decisions are like quick
drying cement you know if you're going
to once you make them it gets really
hard mean you know choosing which
propellants to use in a vehicle you know
selecting LG for the booster stage and
selecting hydrogen for the upper
stage that has turned out to be a very
good decision but if you changed your
mind that would be a very that would be
a very big setback do you see what I'm
saying yeah so that's the kind of
decision you scrutinize very very
carefully other things just aren't like
that most decisions are not that way
most decisions should be made by single
individuals but they need and and and
done quickly
in the full understanding that you can
always change your mind yeah one of the
things I really liked perhaps this not
two-way door decisions is uh I disagree
and commit phrase so don't so somebody
brings up an idea to you if it's a
two-way door you state that you don't
understand enough to agree but you still
back them I'd love to explain it yeah
disagree and commit is really important
principle that saves a lot of arguing
yeah so you know I'm going to use that
in my personal life I disagree but
commit like it's very common in any
Endeavor in life in business and any you
know anybody where you have teammates
you have a teammate and the two of you
disagree yeah at some point you have to
make a decision and you know in
companies we tend to organize
hierarchically so there's this you know
whoever is the more senior person
ultimately gets to make the decision so
ultimately the CEO gets to make that
decision and the CEO may not always make
the decision that they agree with so
like you know I'll I would often I would
be the one who would disagree and commit
some one of my dra reports would very
much want to do it do something in a
particular way I would think it was a
bad idea I would explain my point of
view they would say I Jeff I think
you're wrong and here's why and we would
go back and forth and I would often say
you know what I don't think you're right
um but I'm GNA gamble with you and um
you're closer to the ground truth than I
am I'd known you for 20 years you have
great
judgment I don't know that I'm right
either not really not for sure all these
decisions are complicated let's do it
your way but at least then you've made a
decision and and I'm agreeing to commit
to that decision so I'm not going to be
second guessing it I'm not going to be
sniping at it I'm not going to be saying
I told you so I'm going to try actively
to help make sure it works that's a
really important teammate Behavior
there's so many ways that dispute
resolution is a really interesting thing
in on teams and there are so many ways
when two people disagree about something
even they I'm assuming on the case where
everybody's well-intentioned they just
have a very different opinion about what
the right decision is and we have in our
society and inside companies we have a
bunch of um mechanisms that we use to
resolve these kinds of disputes a lot of
them are I think really bad so an
example of a really bad way of coming to
agreement is
compromise so compromise you know look I
here's we're in a room here and I could
say Lex how tall do you think this
ceiling is and you'd be like I don't
know Jee Maybe 12T tall and I would say
I I think it's 11t tall and then um we'd
say you know what let's just call it 11
and a half
feet that's compromised instead of the
right thing to do is you know to get a
tape measure or figure out some way of
actually measuring but think getting
that tape measure and figure out how to
get it to the top of the ceiling and all
these things that requires energy
compromise the advantage of compromise
as a resolution mechan ism is that it's
low
energy um but it doesn't lead to truth
and so uh in things like the height of
the ceiling where truth is a knowable
thing you shouldn't allow compromise to
be used when you can know the
truth um another really bad resolution
mechanism that happens all the time is
just who's more
stubborn yeah this is also you have
let's say two Executives who disagree
and they just have a war of attrition
and whichever one gets exhausted first
capitulates to the other one again you
haven't arrived at truth and this is
very
demoralizing so you know this is where
escalation I I try to ask people who you
know on my team is say never get to a
point where you are resolving something
by you know who gets exhausted
first escalate that I'll help you make
the decision like let's because that's
so so de-energizing and such a terrible
lousy way to make a decision do you want
to get to the resolution as quickly as
possible because that ultimately leads
to high velocity of the yes and you want
to try to get as close to truth as
possible so you want like you know
exhausting the other person is not truth
seeking yes and compromise is not truth
seeking so you know it doesn't mean now
and there are a lot of cases where no
one knows the real truth and that's
where disagree and commit can come in um
but it's it's um escalation is better
than War of Attrition escalate to you
know to your boss and say hey we can't
agree on this we like each other we're
respectful of each other but we strongly
disagree with each other we need you to
you know make a decision here so we can
move forward but decisiveness moving
forward quickly on on decisions as
quickly as as you responsibly can is how
you increase velocity most of what slows
things down is and is take too long to
make decisions at all skill levels you
know so it has to be part of the
culture to get high velocity you know
Amazon has a million and a half people
and the company is still fast we're
still decisive we're still quick and
that's because the culture supports that
at every scale in a in a distributed way
try to maximize the velocity of
decisions
exactly